one of 2017 s biggest stories is the
launch of the Nintendo switch and they
were pretty hard to find but if someone
on your nice list happens to pick one up
boy do we have something for you
this is game spots holiday gift guide
for the Nintendo switch first thing we
want to recommend is the official
Nintendo pro controller for the switch
there's no better game pad for the
Nintendo switch than the pro controller
due to its soft tactile buttons and
triggers and it's precise analog sticks
this thing can work wirelessly and off
of a full charge it can last up to 40
hours the pro controller has thick
gripping handles which makes them easier
to hold in the joy con it's
ergonomically superior and if they don't
have one already this would make a nice
gift if you still want to gift the
controller for the switch you can get a
little fancier and got either 8-bit news
SF 30 pro or SN 30 pro as you can see
these are modeled after the Super
Famicom and Super Nintendo controllers
with a few modern touches like dual
analog sticks triggers and Bluetooth
wireless connection all you have to do
is sync it up to your switch and they're
good to go these controllers charge
through USB C and can last up to 16
hours but one thing to note is that the
vibration can get loud the Nintendo
switch has a 3.5 millimeter audio jack
which means you can pretty much use any
wired audio device on it but if you're
looking for the perfect headset for the
switch I would recommend the SteelSeries
arc this three bluetooth headset and
there are a couple reasons why the
artist 3 is comfortable and light on
your head they sound great and they do
two things
it gets you your switch game sound
through a 3.5 millimeter audio cable but
it connects via bluetooth to any other
audio device for chat this solves
Nintendo's voice chat problems since you
can use apps like discord and hear your
game simultaneously the console itself
only has 32 gigabytes of internal
storage so switch owners are gonna need
one of these this is a 128 gigabyte
micro SDXC card to download your games
and save files on the Nintendo switch
the one I have right here is officially
licensed by Nintendo made by SanDisk but
any micro SDXC card out there will do
the trick
the next item on our list is for the
folkore a little careless with their
Nintendo switch
y'all are gonna need the case the one I
have here is the official Nintendo case
it'll keep the console perfectly in
place and this flap right here lets you
store a couple games it also let you
prop up your switch this is a semi-hard
case that'll help protect your switch
but there are others out there from
companies like RDS and Horry while we're
on the topic of keeping your switch safe
you've got a screen protector this
particular package from powera comes
with two screen protectors and an
applicator to make sure that there
aren't any air bubbles when it's applied
for faster internet connection on the
switch you can get a USB Ethernet
adapter obviously the console can
connect through Wi-Fi but a wired
connection will get you faster download
speeds and a more stable internet
connection when playing multiplayer
games we're almost done here but to make
sure your gifties switch battery is
never done get them the Anchor Power
Core Plus this particular model of the
Power Core Plus is twenty thousand one
hundred milliamp hours which roughly
estimates the charging your switch from
zero to a hundred about four times over
this would be much appreciated for those
who like to take their switch on the go
and can't always plug in all the time
now if you still can't decide on a gift
for a Nintendo switch owner you can
always get them an eShop gift card this
will act as currency on Nintendo's
digital storefront and they can choose
any games or add-ons that they want to
download to their switch keep in mind
that the eShop cards only come in values
of ten dollars twenty dollars
thirty-five dollars and fifty dollars
those are all the essentials that would
make great gifts for any Nintendo switch
owner this holiday season now all you
have to do is pick one out and watch the
smile on their face as they open it up
if you need even more ideas for presents
you can head on over to GameSpot comm
and check out all our gift guides thanks
for watching and we'll see you soon
[Music]